[Music]
it's time for a very fun new segment
where
i let tarik take the reins and thrill
you with one of the many
exciting stories he's shared with me
over the years this
is terex story time
[Music]
oh hello and welcome to tax story time
i've got a wonderful selection of
stories for you today
but first let's begin with the story
about the first time i went to a
baseball game
oh the bell went off you know what that
means
it's time for us to go and see the kind
of special letters people send to me
maybe there's a package even two or
three because anything can come in the
mail
i said anything can come in the mail
howdy ever hi mailman mark my bell went
off
so i guess that means you have some
special mail for me sure do
open it and see whoa
this is a fan letter all the way from
iceland
wow yeah and this
is a reminder for me to take my car in
for service
hey that's always important too well see
ya
um wait mailman mark
is there any chance my stimulus check
has come in the mail yet
uh i don't think so maybe next time
of course next time thanks mark
oh sorry about that tarek oh no no no no
apology needed
you got to get the mail as soon as it
comes i understand thank you
but please continue with the story
so anyway baseball it was a warm and
spring day and there was a guy
selling peanuts oh my gosh there's the
bell again
you better go get that mail it's time
for us to
go and see the very special things
people send to me
i know i'm gonna love it i can guarantee
because anything can come in the mail
i totally have anything to come in the
mail howdy amber
welcome back mailman mark another
delivery in the same day what are the
chances
hey it must be a pretty special one
right sure
is here you go oh my gosh about time
i feel like i've been waiting forever to
what what's this gee it looks like an
invitation to a prestigious dinner of
some sort
wowie zowie isn't that nice
i was really expecting it to be the
stimulus check
oh sorry about that not today maybe next
time though
said that last time mark what what was
that nothing mark bye
okey-dokey i'm really sorry terrick i
didn't mean to interrupt again
hey hey don't worry about it you know
but i i do feel like it's
a little hard to keep telling the story
there's such a rhythm to it do you mind
if i uh pick another one
sure thing okay
this is a story all about the time i did
a very nice drawing of a woman i met
the year was 1912 and i had just boarded
the
rms titanic
oh boy the bell again third time's the
charm i guess
it's time for us to go and see body blah
blah blah blah be
whatever whatever here's the mail
where's the mail mark give me my mail
wait what the hell is this you've been
selected for a special trip through mr
monkly's candy factory wow
i don't want a tour of a dang candy
factory i want my stimulus check
where's my money stupid puppet oh
i think you're directing your anger in
the wrong direction i'm just a messenger
wow oh stop saying that i am so sick of
you
how long are we supposed to be doing
this before they actually send us the
money they keep promising
i mean we've been waiting forever oh i
got mine already
you did yeah i use it to uh custom order
or book up
all my stories i got mine too oh and
what did you invest
yours in mail or something stupid like
that no i used it to feed my family of
four
the federal government declared my
position essential but not so essential
that they're paying me a living wage
i'm glad i got my stimulus check to
ensure that my family wouldn't have to
continue struggling through the final
few months of the pandemic
what were you gonna use yours for
a little scooter for my desk so i don't
have to walk
all this way for the mail not a very far
distance but
okay i guess we all have different
thresholds for what sort of
inconvenience make us insult our mail
man
wowie zoey wow is owie
indeed tale of privilege
a failing government and a scooter
tale of america this has been
tarik story time
[Music]
[Applause]
you